[Musica]
Ciao bambini Benvenuti in una serie di
quattro video chiamata Mamma ho 30 anni
e ho i soldi miei personali non uso i
tuoi vado nei negozi a comprarmi i
giochi va bene non mi puoi fermare
appunto i miei genitori quando ero
piccola hanno sempre cercato di non
farmi mai mancare nulla male finanze
erano quello che erano ed io essendo un
bimbo scemo L'unica cosa che volevo
erano sempre i giocattoli degli altri
mai quelli che avevo io e guarda caso
erano sempre quelli più interessanti ed
è questo quello che ho deciso di fare
prendere parte dei miei soldi e comprare
usati perché non esistono più alcuni dei
giochi che ho sempre voluto ormai
diventati rarissime Oh bambini La
Fabbrica dei mostri che cosa non era
questo incredibile giocattolo questo
forno che serviva a creare mostri dal
nulla doveva essere mio doveva essere
mio ma non lo era dovevo sempre andare a
casa di qualcun altro a vederli con quel
gioco perché Guai a toccarlo con mano
mia Ci mancherebbe e non me la sono
legata al dito io questa cosa qua no non
sbatto tutto quello che voglio io qua e
mio lo ricompro guarda un po' Guarda
come lo ribalto tamponatemi La droga fa
male bimbi La droga fa male Io non mi
drogo penso è tutto partiva sempre dalle
pubblicità dagli spot pubblicitari in
mezzo ai cartoni animati La fabbricate i
mostri ha aperto Gigi
dai 2 il forno spolerà infila la piastra
sfila il tuo mostro ancora a memoria me
la ricordo sta cazzo di pubblicità
Guarda Ha aperto giù in città hanno
stirato un gatto in strada Senti che
roba cioè la fabbrica dei mostri bacino
che 100 100 ha rovinato un sacco di
famiglie monetariamente e secondo me
anche psicologicamente Io mi ricordo
altri tipi di pubblicità Comunque ce n'è
un'altra con una scena che non mi
dimenticherò mai
finestra sfila il tuo mostro Tu pensa
essere il bambino a cui hanno fatto
uscire gli occhi fuori dalle orbite per
vedere quello che poi non è uno del
mosso della fabbrica di mostri non è è
tutto oro è un'altra cosa la vera
fabbrica dei mostri fabbrica dei mostri
e questo bimbo che doveva dire con
questo bimbo doveva dire con la vera
fabbrica dei mostri e non l'hanno
ridoppiato la vera fabbrica dei mostri
farfuglia qualcosa che non è
propriamente quello e c'è anche una
terza pubblicità che è fatta con la
sigla del cartone animato Perché sì
C'era il cartone animato della Fabbrica
dei mostri
[Musica]
che è ovvio un prodotto come un dolce
forno demoniaco non può che avere
un'ottima trama per una per una serie
animata per bambini e io la vedevo Però
rosicavo come una bestia perché stavo
guardando una serie animata di un
giocattolo che non avevo Perché il mio
cervello funziona così io non riesco a
utilizzare manco le gif di serie TV che
non ho visto perché mi sento in colpa ad
utilizzarle perché non le ho viste
figurati guardare un'intera serie
animata o dei problemi bambini che mi
ascoltate da casa provate ad andare a
cercare nell'ufficio di vostro padre
dietro i mobili di vostra madre in
camera dei vostri genitori se c'è
qualche necrologio degli anni 90 per
vedere quanti vostri compari sono morti
ingerendo un mostro gelatinoso della
Fabbrica dei mostri così per curiosità
nel 1964 la Mattel si chiese Come
possiamo uccidere il maggior numero di
bambini creando uno dei giocattoli più
pericolosi della storia la prima
fabbrica di mostri chiamati in originale
Creepy crawler era una piccola trappola
mortale a partire dall'inquietantissima
ma estremamente affascinante scatola che
aveva un'illustrazione spaventosamente
lovecraft Diana ma bella Ma proprio
bella bella da quasi io me la farei
stampare a prendere da qualche parte
seriamente e la fabbrica in sé Era un
piccolo incubo era questo fornelletto
quasi da campeggio sembrerebbe a gas
dove tu mettevi sopra una piastra di
ferro con dentro il il liquido per fare
i mostri tutto all'aperto non c'era la
copertura di plastica non c'era nessuno
protezione si scaldava lì sul momento e
tu poi con le pinze con la presina di
tua mamma con le mani a mani nude
prendevi questo Ferro rovente e lo
dovevi lasciare da qualche parte a ah ah
a raffreddare ad asciugare e non solo si
è scoperto che in questa versione del 64
i fumi che tu inalavi erano altamente
tossici ma rischiavi anche di avere
delle ustioni di terzo grado e quarto
grado sulle mani per poter prendere
queste cose qui anche perché la fabbrica
di mostri era mirata ad un pubblico
molto piccolo e non vuoi che una decina
di centinaia di migliaia di bambini
vedendo la gelatinosità del prodotto i
suoi colori non se ne siano pappati
alcuni finendo al pronto soccorso o
addirittura peggio Ed infatti nel 78
stopparono la produzione per poi
riprenderla grazie a thoimax nel 92
mettendo in sicurezza il prodotto
mettendogli la plastica intorno e ed
evitando che fosse riscaldata
elettronicamente ma semplicemente con
una lampadina e per ovviare a voi i
bambini disgraziati di quelli che si
mangiano Qualsiasi cosa gli metti in
mano fecero anche una linea di Creepy
crawlers mangiabili gli Incredible
edibles che erano un po' un sogno per i
genitori con i bambini che si mangiavano
qualsiasi cosa da terra ma chi se ne
frega di tutte queste informazioni
apriamo finalmente la fabbrica di mostri
originale
voi non avete la minima idea di quanto
io sia impazzendo in questo momento ho
la fabbrica dei mostri Finalmente tra le
mie mani tra l'altro Il logo è veramente
strano perché è palesemente un forno per
pizze a legna di Pietra e non il forno
colorato Che c'è per fare i mostri Oh
Madonna mia Allora ehm apriamola
funziona solo con una lampadina da 24
watt dice speriamo sia dentro
Questo è il manuale ma più con manuali
d'istruzione è esattamente è una nota
per i genitori perché giustamente è un
forno che stai dando a un tuo bambino di
4 anni controllo da effettuarsi prima di
giocare il giocatore fornito da una
lampadina da montare il montaggio dovrà
essere effettuato mettere l'interruttore
sulla posizione cioè sollevare lo
sportello lasciare cadere
Scusa un bambino a Natale apre la
scatola della Fabbrica dei mostri perché
vorrebbe subito giocare e invece no 4
ore e mezza i genitori si fanno due
[ __ ] così alla notte di Natale
finiscono alle 3:00 del mattino per fare
poi un mostro così
una la la la come si chiama la così la
paletta per le pizze che schifo che in
che condizioni pietose sono mettiamo la
spina
[Musica]
Chissà se riusciamo a morire fulminati
in uno di questi episodi ho comprato le
piastrine dei Power Rangers ovviamente
dei Power Rangers Certo che fai conto
sono due stampi la spatola e due colori
e la scatola è più grande della fabbrica
Cioè mi sembra un po' esagerato
e di Gesù non me ne ero accorto e la
scatola solo di Jason il Power Ranger
rosso Tra l'altro della serie originale
[Musica]
non riesco ad accenderla
Ti prego è bellissima si illumina Tutta
che se non scaldasse così tanto Sarebbe
un'ottima lampada notturna per bambini
Alla peggio Si brucia tutta la casa
Vabbè poi sono cazzi tuoi lì non so cosa
fare se fare il pezzo di Megazord o una
posizione a caso di Jason oh oh
ne ho messo un po' troppo No ho
sbagliato prima Quello bianco sembra
molto liquido ok
ora la parte difficile è metterli dentro
[Musica]
ce l'ho fatta alla prima botta
campionissimo chiudo e accendo ci vuole
una ventina di minuti quindi
pausina - caffè Pausini E si torna fra
20 minuti Ma tu pensa la rottura di
cazzo di fare sta roba la notte di
Natale
[Musica]
la fabbrica si è spenta Quindi in teoria
ha finito di cuocere con la lampadina
però l'ho lasciata 10 minuti perché si
deve raffreddare ora la parte più
difficile probabilmente che quella di
bollente quella di prendere il piattino
con e lo sapevo
strano che non l'abbiano mai più fatto
questo gioco nei negozi strano sembra
tutto abbastanza uniforme la gamba
sembra un po' spappolata Però è da
raffreddare e da raffreddare perché l'ho
toccato con la spatolina ed era uno
yogurt Quindi aspettiamo un attimo
No si registra tutto non è un giocattolo
per giocare ma è un giocattolo per
vantarti con gli amici la mattina dopo
che vai a scuola serve soltanto per
insultare i tuoi amici piccoli
disgraziati poveri vedi sai che non so
se è pronto provo a togliere il calcio
veramente con tanta tanta tanta
Eccolo qui questo è Jason che tira
[Risate]
Questo è l'altro questo qui è l'altro
però li vedi i dettagli dell'Elmo
sono i due Jason Dunque abbiamo lasciato
passare un po' di tempo e abbiamo
provato a fare un'altra formina quella
di un ragno l'abbiamo fatto verde e
marrone perché quelli sono i colori
pensavo fosse rosso invece era marrone
ed è venuto perfetto sembra la sua cena
pezzi di carne
[Musica]
Ti prego bellissimo
che tragedia Ammazza che è inutile che
forse è un bene che i miei genitori non
abbiano speso tuttisti i soldi per fare
piccolissimi giocattoli di gomma che non
userò mai però per il video mi è valsa
la pena mi sono divertito molto È stato
bello
Dimmi Mi sono girato una marea di Toys
Center per questa serie entro e trovo
questa colonna alta fino al cielo di
giocattoli di Topo Gigio nel 2022 di
Topo Gigio Io ero convinto che la
fabbrica dei mostri fosse sparita negli
anni 90 e mentre stavo spulciando
giocattoli a caso alzo lo sguardo e mi
trovo
Creepy kroers E che fai Non te ne compri
una scatola Mi raccomando bambini quando
volete aprire delle scatole ma avete
soltanto delle forbici terribilmente a
punta Fatevi aiutare dai vostri genitori
oppure se Volete ferire dei vostri amici
Queste sono perfette
Oh Madonna Insomma uguale Abbiamo finito
di montarla e ed è un pezzo di plastica
non è elettrica
Ecco qui c'è il blisterino dimostri già
perfettamente fatti e quindi non serve a
niente Grazie mille per essere passati
se tu prenditimostri già fatti li spremi
per creare la creatura perfetta
praticamente va messo in microonde
bambini Se volete affumicare tutta la
vostra famiglia avvelenarvi secondo me
si può fare due verdi e uno arancione
prego su c'è il microonde Mi raccomando
non facciamo esplodere tutta la casa qui
m'è rimasto un pezzo staccato Non so
dove usarlo questo qui
che è successo c'era un tappo da mettere
Ah forse sì ecco cos'era un tappo questo
è salvabile Ma ti prego cari muffa Ma
perché a quanto pare no tu sei un
cretino Scusami ma come si fa a lavorare
così dobbiamo fare un programma per
bambini e non sappiamo noi usare i
giochi ora bisogna metterlo tutto girato
verso le frecce io Ora proverò a
schiacciarlo sperando che il liquido poi
riempia io mi Dubito altamente Però
proviamo
Oh mamma mia che schifo va messo in
frigo
quindi oltre al microonde serve un
frigorifero Mi raccomando eh chiedete ai
vostri genitori Eccoci qui dopo un paio
di minuti in frigorifero il nostro
sgorbio è pronto
non è venuto un cazzo non è venuto un
cazzo grazie mille per aver visto questo
episodio noi ci vediamo al prossimo Ciao
bambini
Mortacci sua
oggi vi proponiamo
nordvpn Come già sapete con nordvpn
potete proteggere i vostri dati quando
vi connettete alle reti pubbliche e
Cambiare IP scegliendo quello di un
paese diverso dal vostro ma fa molto più
di quello state navigando online e non
riuscite a capire dove cazzo comprare
una fabbrica dei mostri usata non VPN vi
protegge anche dai siti web dannosi E
dai file infetti da malware vi può far
navigare su internet senza lasciare
alcuna traccia e vi blocca i pop-up se
manco quello riuscite a fare con il
mouse Nord VPN è lì che vi aiuta e per i
primi 30 abbonamenti regalano anche un
set di pentole in acciaio una una
bicicletta con cambio Shimano Vabbè ma
almeno il codice sconto
Vabbè il codice sconto Io Toby in
descrizione alle prime 30 telefonate